guten morgen herr klitschko
ich konnte sie jetzt gerade nicht
verstehen wir testen den ton
jetzt kann ich sie hören ja ich habe
guten morgen gesagt ein guter morgen hab
auch beantworten wollen ein guter morgen
ist es natürlich nicht bei ihnen in kiew
sie sind in deutschland dieses gute
morgen 9
999 na gut sie haben ja nur noch nicht
verloren das ist gut erzählen sie uns
wie war die herausrücken wir werden auch
diesen krieg gewinnen
wie war die nacht erklärte lohse krieg
gewinnen ihr habt ja die gesprochen ein
bisschen zu ihr mit technik mit allem
drum und dran
der gegner
hatte nicht der wille
unseren zielen zu zerbrechen
wille zur freiheit willi frey war weil
die ukraine genommen haben ist sie nicht
lugansk oder tony skinn im sinne oder
cream in dem sinne auch wir sind die
ganze ukraine und der wille hre menschen
ist nicht so ziemlich keine atomwaffen
könig strafen nichts weil der wille ist
die stärkste kraft und die stärkste
waffe die man besitzen sie sind ein
kämpfer und sie haben ein kämpferherz
natürlich herr klitschko aber was können
sie uns konkret berichtende wie war bei
ihnen die nacht wir haben dass bilder
die bilder des brennenden hochhauses
gerade gesehene wo eine rakete oder eine
us missile eingeschlagen ist wie war die
nacht und was erwarten sie für diesen
tag es ist unglaublich wie eigentlich
schnell ein mensch sich angewöhnt
anständiges
die chance bombardierung
das ist schon seit vier nächten die in
kiel zu hören und nicht nur hören
sondern zu sehen auch mit den bildern
menschen die ihre lieben verloren
menschen die ukraine sind auf dem
griechischen boden schlagen russische
ergebnis und auszudrucken zu
aber wie ich schon gesagt habe
wir sind bereit das land zu verteidigen
dazu stehen dass das appetit ist groß
bei der operation und der narr unsere
motivation ist unser land ja sie und
unsere tiere die in die schule gehen und
wir werden das bis zum letzten tag des
blutes beteiligen das klingt sehr
martialisch herr klitschko bis zum
letzten tropfen des blutes was erwarten
sie für heute für diesen tag könnte das
ein entscheidender tag heute werden für
jeden tag ist entscheidend jeden tag ist
entscheidend wir wissen nicht ob wir den
tag für morgen erleben werden aber
bestimmt verhält wie gesagt die
motivation ist wahnsinnig stark dass das
habe ich selbst nie gesehen bei den
menschen die die freiwillig das land
beteiligen wollen mit allen mitteln mit
allen mitteln man kann nicht schlafen
diesen will zu zerbrechen es ist nicht
aus glas gemacht wurden und nicht aus
betont vielmehr gestärkt und
letztendlich es geht um europa es geht
du den frieden in europa seit zweiten
weltkrieg diese stadt hat nicht er die
bombardierungen sind zweiten weltkriegs
war das noch nie wieder zu hören aber
von vier tagen passiert ist und wer hat
das angegriffen wer hat das gemacht die
nachbarn
ist schwer zu fassen wie weit man gehen
kann aber es ist einfach nur brutale
mord an die bevölkerung menschen
versuchte mord an die demokratie und
freie wahl und das wären die nicht
schafft
klitschko wir sind vor allem die männer
meiner wie sie die jetzt kennen und
schätzen sie nicht jüdischen frauen
nicht nur gut aussehende frau soll in
diesem körper unglaublich ja das klar
welche und deshalb wollte ich sie fragen
es gibt eine frau die ist im
hungerstreik
was können sie uns darüber erzählen
ja ich habe das auch mitbekommen
von der frau die die ist einfach
verloren weil die kann die kinder nicht
schützen wahrscheinlich bald nicht mehr
ernähren erinnerte er an blockade von
leningrad damaligen
heutzutage und also macht er sucht die
stadt so an kessel und die frau ist für
zweiten sie hat kinder sie hat nichts
mit dem krieg zu tun ist jene
weiterkommen und ich verstehe die
motivation sagte weißt du was
scheißegal
angestrahlt streit
ich will damit die welt zeigen dass wir
in der ukraine
drei
demokratischer weil mit jedem mittel zu
beteiligen auch sie das sehr was
letztendlich es ist unglaublich aber
damit für so sie auf ihre art und weise
zeigen ich kann vielleicht ein
kalaschnikow oder eine andere waffe im
hand halten ich habe die kinder ich muss
ich muss mich um die kinder können aber
wahrscheinlich das einzige das die welt
sieht wie brutal das ist gerade ist
nicht nur militär leute zivilisten
kinder sie schon gestorben wie kann es
sein
20 22 haben wir nicht von der
vergangenheit gelernt
von der seele die in der vergangenheit
gemacht worden was ist mit dieser welt
los
klitschko sie sind der bruder von vitali
klitschko wie jeder weiß ist der
bürgermeister von kiew wie müssen wir
uns das vorstellen sind sie beide die
ganze zeit zusammen schlafen sie auch im
selben haus in derselben wohnung sind
sie in ständigem kontakt was schon an
der frage wie sind schon seit lassen sie
mich nach zählen seit 45 jahren zusammen
aber eher sagen sie jetzt konkret wie
ist das jetzt in kiew vor ort sind sie
da die ganze zeit zusammen und beraten
sich auch gegenseitig was jetzt zu tun
ist
sie wussten sie wie sie wollen natürlich
alles wissen wir sind immer zusammen
seit 45 jahren ich brauche nicht in die
details gehen und wir haben sie nie
genug zeiten der sendung also für des
jahres schon lange stück zu erzählen
herr klitschko wir wünschen ihnen alles
gute für diesen tag ging und allen kiew
danke dass sie sich die zeit genommen
haben und
nur das beste danke alles gute